I don't believe it's okay for my daughter to become a housewife,
and I will never tell my daughter that.
I make it abundantly clear that absolutely the fuck not.
No, you will not become. No,
you will not become a fucking housewife.
I'm not raising you
so that you could just go off and become somebody's personal
fucking custom servant in the. No,
no, no,
no.
It will never be things I'm gonna teach my children that are not okay.
Number one, doing drugs.
Number one, abusing alcohol and other substances. Number three,
being a shitty person. Number four,
becoming a housewife to anybody.
I'm not gonna encourage my son to become a piece of shit
that expects things out of women.
Even though he's got three sisters,
one mother, and even a female dog,
he still does every chore in the house that everybody else does.
They take turns doing a little bit of everything
as appropriate for their age.
Um, like,
I couldn't say no. No, no, no,
no more to this. I don't know what else to say, but, like, no.
I will never teach my daughter.
And any girl that I come in contact with,
I will be like, you know that that shit's a lie.
If it sounds too good to be true,
it is. So don't fall for it.
Make sure you always have your shit covered.